- [Sal] I'm here with Eman El-Sheikh,
Khan Academy's World History Fellow.
The question I have, Eman, is,
history often focuses on men,
but clearly, women were
playing a significant role,
but how much can we know about
women, say, 2,000 years ago?
- [Eman] So, when we talk about the lives
of women in the Classical Period,
sometimes we're tempted to
compare it to the modern day,
and that can cause some problems
because that's not
really a fair comparison.
So it's more useful to
see how different women
living in different societies
in the same time period
compare to one another.
That can make their
differences a lot more salient
and give us a better idea.
Of course, it's hard to know the history
of women back then in general.
We don't necessarily have
all the best sources.
But we can try to piece
together some understanding
of what their daily lives were like.
- [Sal] We have two
points of reference here;
one from Rome as it transitions
from republic to empire;
and another from Han China.
Let's look at the reference from Rome.
Just for a little bit of context,
this speech that we're gonna talk about,
this occurs in 42 BCE.
People might remember
that in 44 BCE you have
Julius Caesar getting
assassinated on the Ides of March,
and it throws the Roman
Empire into a civil war.
And so, this speech is
given during that civil war.
Because civil wars,
they're not just bloody,
they're also expensive,
and to fund that civil war
the triumvirs decide to tax
the 1400 wealthiest women.
Hortensia, who gives this speech,
is one of those wealthy women.
- [Eman] Hortensia says:
"Why should we pay taxes
"when we do not share
in the offices, honors,
"military commands, nor,
in short, the government,
"for which you fight between yourselves
"with such harmful results?
"You say 'because it is wartime.'
"When has there not been war?
"and when have women paid taxes?
"By nature of their sex women are absolved
"from paying taxes among all mankind.
"Our mothers did once
rise superior to their sex
"and made contributions
when you faced the loss
"of the empire and the city itself
"through the conflict
with the Carthaginians.
"But they funded their
contributions voluntarily
"from their jewelry not
from their landed property,
"their fields, their
dowries, or their houses,
"without which it is impossible
for free women to live...
"Let war with the Celts or Parthians come,
"we will not be inferior to our mothers
"when it is a question of common safety.
"But for civil wars,
may we never contribute
"nor aid you against each other.
"We did not pay taxes
to Caesar or to Pompey,
"nor did Marius ask us for contributions,
"nor Cinna, nor Sulla,
"even though he was a
tyrant over this country.
"And you say that you are
reestablishing the Republic!"
- [Sal] Wow, that was quite powerful.
And there's a lot of richness here.
What's your takeaway?
- [Eman] So, it's interesting
that she is saying that
by nature of their sex women
are absolved from paying taxes.
It might seem like she's
saying that women are weaker;
but she's sort of speaking
back to this requirement
that they should use their property.
Because they're normally using
jewelry and they're normally
using things that they
don't necessarily need
in order to fight off foreigners.
Here she's really taking issue with having
to use her livelihood
to support a civil war,
and she's sort of taking
them to task on this,
that they're worse than
tyrants for asking this of her.
- [Sal] The other thing
that jumps out of this,
it comes outta the first few statements,
"Why should we pay taxes
when we do not share
"in the offices, honors,
military commands,
"nor, in short, the government."
She's making very clear, women
don't get to participate.
Why should we fund this war?
I also like this part.
"You say 'because it is wartime.'
"When has there not been war?"
That's a really good point, because Rome,
especially at that point,
was continuously conquering
other peoples, continuously at war,
sometimes a civil war,
sometimes an external war.
- [Eman] Sure, and I
think it's interesting how
she's pointing to that disparity between
the things that men have
and women don't have.
And she's just trying to say:
"Well, if that's how it's
"going to be, then we should
also be exempt from taxation."
I think that's an interesting
way to voice concerns.
While this might seem very primitive
to our modern sensibilities,
it's really powerful that a woman
is taking these government
officials to task
and being so outspoken
and quite scathing in
the way she does this.
- [Sal] I also like the
second part right over here,
where she is citing that our
mothers once also stepped up.
She's referring to, during
the Second Punic War
and Hannibal was running
amuck on the Italian Peninsula
and even threatening Rome
itself, that the women of Rome,
especially the wealthy women of Rome,
did step up and pay taxes.
- [Eman] So, based on this,
Sal, what do you think we can
learn about Roman women and
their lives at this time period?
- [Sal] Well, as we pointed
out, even in this speech
she cites some direct reference
to not having equality to men.
But on the other hand,
she has stormed the triumvirs' tribunal.
I think this is the first
time that women were,
they weren't even allowed
there, they just went there,
and she's sticking it to the
triumvirs pretty strongly.
She's saying: "Let war with
the Celts or Parthians come,
"we will not be inferior to our mothers."
"We're willing to step up if
it's war with external parties.
"But for civil wars,
may we never contribute
"nor aid you against each other."
They're saying: "Hey, if
you wanna fight yourself,
"that's your problem."
And she's even telling 'em: "And you say
"that you are reestablishing
the Republic!"
She's questioning the three most
powerful people in the Roman Empire.
She's questioning their very intention.
So it does show, at least culturally,
even if officially women
do not have a strong role,
at least these elite women
do have enough comfort
to be able to go to
the three most powerful
in the Roman Empire and stick it to them.
- [Eman] Yeah, and while this
may not seem like a big deal
to us now, we have to avoid
that comparison, like I said.
If we compare it to some other societies
around the same time,
this is quite remarkable
for a woman to enter a public institution.
Again, she is an elite woman,
but let's compare it to,
say, Athenian women, even
elite woman in Athens,
were not likely to have any involvement
in the political institutions,
were a lot more likely to just
remain in the private sphere,
were not likely to be as
educated as Roman women.
And so, the fact that
Hortensia can actually
enter into the space and be so outspoken
is sort of evidence of
the fact that Roman women
had a degree more freedom than other women
who were their contemporaries
in other societies.
- [Sal] Absolutely.
Let's continue that comparison.
We can go about 100, 150 years further
in the future from Hortensia's speech.
Let's also go to the other side of,
almost the other side of the world,
we'll go to eastern Asia,
where we are in the Eastern Han Dynasty.
So here we have some text from Ban Zhao,
who was a female historian,
astronomer, mathematician,
Confucian, philosopher, coauthor of
the official history book of Han.
It's from her Lessons for Women.
- [Eman] So, Ban Zhao says:
"Let a woman modestly yield to others;
"let her respect others;
let her put others first.
"Herself, last."
"Lay the (girl) baby
at birth below the bed
"to plainly indicate that
she is lowly and weak,
"and should regard it as her primary duty
"to humble herself before others."
"A husband can marry twice, but
his wife must never remarry.
"Just as Heaven cannot be disobeyed,
"so the wife cannot keep
away from her husband."
"Man is honored for strength;
"a woman is beautiful on
account of her gentleness."
- [Sal] So what's your take on that?
- [Eman] So, this is very much inline
with the Confucian ideal of womanhood,
and that's very much about a woman being
very submissive to her male
relatives, and for her to stay
very modest within the power
framework of her society,
and to stay pretty much
within her own household,
and to cultivate a life that
is meant to create comfort
for the men in her
family and her children,
and not much more than that.
- [Sal] Yeah, I could not
imagine anyone who read this
and took it seriously as
doing a lesson for themselves
and storming the triumvirs' tribunals,
even if they are an elite
woman in imperial China.
- [Eman] Certainly, but I think
there's an important thing
to remember, and that this
kind of document shows
a prescriptive approach to women's lives.
And that doesn't necessarily mean
that women did live this way.
The fact that Ban Zhao
herself is writing this
is sort of ironic
because she's a woman who
is putting herself out
there and writing things
and not staying in the private sphere,
so that's sort of a strange
contradiction there.
But also, women who had a lot of wealth
were likely to become educated like her.
And also, it sort of
depended on their generation.
Older women were likely
to have inheritances,
property, just like
their Roman counterparts,
and they were more likely
to engage in trade.
We can find this out by
looking at other documents,
like wills and so forth.
So we can sort of see a tension between
the prescriptive Confucian ideals
and how women actually lived.
In a lot of ways, having
wealth allowed women
to buy their way out of these constrictive
practices and ideas about women.
- [Sal] I definitely
agree with that irony.
It's quite thick here, because
she's telling other women
to indicate that she is lowly and weak,
but Ban Zhao herself, as I
mentioned, she's a historian,
astronomer, mathematician,
Confucian, philosopher,
she co-wrote one of the official histories
of the Han empire, she's more
prominent and has done more
than the great majority
of men in her time,
so she's clearly not lowly and weak.
So the irony is quite thick.
- [Eman] Certainly.
It's interesting to look
at these things because,
like you said, it gives us
a sense of the difference.
There seems to be quite
a different culture
at play between Rome
and China at this time.
And so, making that
kinda comparison gives us
a lot more information about women's lives
than simply saying that
there's a single history
for all women of this time period,
and that's simply not the case.
As we can see, there are
huge differences between
the civilizations; certainly,
even within civilizations
there can be huge differences.
- [Sal] Yes.
Both of the examples we looked at
have been very elite women.
We're talking about women
well within the top 1%.
If you went to more average women,
their situation would
have been very different.
- [Eman] Certainly.
So, this idea that women
are supposed to have
a nice home full of family
and stay within that,
only wealthy women could
really live up to that;
because if you have to leave
the house to make a living,
you might not be able to
create this idyllic household
full of children and spend
all your time managing that.
So that's an important
difference, as well.
- [Sal] Thanks, Eman.
This was really valuable.
- [Eman] Thanks, Sal.